while more than a million Game of
Thrones fans found their wish you crying
out for HBO to remake the eighth and
final season with a different group of
writers actress sophie Turner feels that
protests to be incredibly rude and of
course if you didn't realize by now
major spoilers ahead concerning the
series finale of Game of Thrones Turner
who portrayed Sansa Stark on the series
from his premiere episode in 2011 to its
series finale in 2019 address the recent
fan petition has been making headlines
in an interview with the New York Times
created by a change to org user known
only as Dylan D the appeal slams Game of
Thrones series creators showrunners and
frequent directors David Benioff and DB
Weiss the petition accuses Benioff and
Weiss of being woefully incompetent
Wright says when they have no source
material ie the books to fall back on he
you what what does he say about me it
also demands a HBO hire a team of quote
competent writers to create a final
season that makes sense when asked
further thoughts about the uproar from
fans which reached an apex from the
newly minted Mad Queen Daenerys
Targaryen set King's Landing ablaze in
the series second-to-last episode
Turner responded I think the petition is
disrespectful to the crew and the
writers and the filmmakers who have
worked tirelessly over 10 years so many
people worked so so hard on it and for
people to just a rubbish ship because
it's not what they want to see it's just
disrespectful
as Turner notes Game of Thrones has been
subverting expectations a since the very
beginning so why should it change course
at during the final season the actress
told the New York Times the thing about
Game of Thrones has always been amazing
is the fact that there's always been
crazy twists and turns right from season
1 with Ned's beheading so Daenerys
becoming something of the Mad Queen it
shouldn't be such a negative thing for
fans it's a shock for sure but I think
it's just because it hasn't gone their
way Turner is far from the first game of
Thrones star to speak out about audience
backlash Kit Harington who portrayed her
on-screen brother / cousin Jon Snow told
a squire in April that any critic who
makes a negative judgment on the final
season can quote go themselves as he
feels they don't fully understand how
difficult it is to make even one episode
of Game of Thrones Parrington told the
publication I know how much people cared
about this I know how much pressure
people put on themselves and I know how
many sleepless night
working or otherwise people had on this
show because they cared about not
letting people down now if people feel
let down by it I don't give up that's
how I feel the woman whose characters
downfall catalyzed the demand for a
season age remake Daenerys Targaryen
actress Emilia Clarke also recently
opened up about the fun petition
speaking with The New Yorker Clarke
revealed that the mother of dragons
falling from grace to become the mad
Queen and then facing the ultimate
betrayal and Jon Snow murders her quotes
seems like the only way it could end for
Danny Clark told The New Yorker it
absolutely breaks my heart that anyone
would think anything bad of her but I'm
sure they will and I can't control that
I don't know there was any other way on
the other hand Turner's character
completed Iraq in an almost universally
loved way after members of the remaining
great houses of Westeros met with one
another and agreed with Tyrion
Lannister's suggestion that bran stark
should be crowned as the new king Sansa
declared that the north would separate
itself from the other kingdoms stand
independence and never vote on who will
become the protector of the realm
everyone supported Sansa and when she
returned home to Winterfell she was
crowned the queen in the North turn a
set of Santa's ending I loved her it's
the only place that she really truly
feels safe the place that she's the most
capable of ruling
she would be a fair and loving ruler and
this was she's been striving for this
whole series to go back home to protect
her home I want you to help me but I'll
do it myself if I have to though she's
frustrated by the way audiences have
reacted to the final season of Game of
Thrones
Turner isn't letting the negativity
stain her good memories of the series
and what it was like to be a part of it
the actress told the New York Times one
of the things that I remember the most
is just the camaraderie and the family
that we all created from being on the
show I've never felt such a strong bond
with a group of people in my life I know
that they're going to be my family
forever I think that's what I'll take
away the most check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
loop of videos about Game of Thrones are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]